First, let's look at conceptual integrity, which I mentioned earlier in today's
lesson. Let me give you two historical quotes that, that give an idea of what
conceptual integrity is all about. The first is from the philosopher Descartes.
He said of these thoughts on the very first that occurred to me was, that there
is seldom so much perfection in works composed of many separate parts,.
Upon which different hands had been employed,
as in those completed by a single master. More recently, Fred Brooks, in,
The Mythical Man-Month, has said much the same thing. I will contend that
conceptual integrity is the most important consideration in system design.
It is better to have a system omit. Certain anomalous features and
improvements, but to reflect one set of design ideas, then to have one that
contains many independent, and uncoordinated ideas. A couple of related concepts
are coupling and cohesion. These originally came out of structure design, but
they also apply to object orientated design, and other design approaches.
Assuming you've carved your system into separate components, those components
may be coupled to each other. Coupling is the extent to which two components
depend on each other for successful execution. If you think about it for
a minute low coupling is good. After you've delivered your system,
and you have to maintain it. If you have a highly coupled system, and
you change one module, that means that you're likely to have to change other
modules. Whereas if there's low coupling, that likelihood goes down.
A related concept is cohesion. With cohesion we're talking about
a single module, and cohesion is the extent to which that module, or
component has a single purpose or function. High cohesion is good.
For example highly cohesive modules are much more easy to reuse.
They have a single purpose. You need to reuse them to accomplish that purpose.